here's to the next 50 years hey
youtubers it's Charlie happy geek week
so since there's so much Marvel stuff
going on this weekend and I just did a
low-key video I thought it'd be really
cool to do an update on x-men days of
future past there have been so many
behind-the-scenes pictures and teasers
that have come out since Comic Con I
thought it'd be really fun to talk some
mutants let's talk about geek week for
since Marvel debuted a new trailer for
super Wednesday that's basically like
superhero Wednesday Bryan Singer was not
one to back down from the challenge
obviously x-men being Fox so different
studio Bryan Singer just posted this
really cool behind-the-scenes image of
them shooting this superfast Quicksilver
seen obviously they had to shoot at a
very high frame rate to simulate the
SuperSpeed motion he said it was about
3600 frames a second so they basically
had to turn the lighting into like
something like a kid to the Sun it was
just super bright just because of the
way cameras work when you shoot that
fast even though they haven't made that
comic con clip from days of future past
public yet bryan singer has been really
really good about giving fans a lot of
teasers and images from behind the
scenes from his twitter account but
don't worry i'll tell you all about that
comic con footage it was really good in
case you haven't seen it it basically
shows us kind of where the story starts
and what some of the biggest beats are
so let's get started so Bryan Singer's
take on Days of Future past is just like
Joss Whedon's take on Avengers age of
Ultron they're just changing a few
things to kind of make it a little more
suitable for a movie than the comic book
or the original stories did for example
they're changing the origin story of
Ultron so obviously some of the things
in Days of Future past are going to be a
little bit different from the comic book
but they honestly they're pretty
faithful so the actual clip starts off
with them in the far future in this
dystopian future where Sentinel so
basically kind of destroyed the world
and they're just kind of living in the
wreckage what happens is the professor x
and the x-men basically have to convince
wolverine to go back in time to let his
mind go back in time to warn these past
x-men that's the first class version of
x men obviously wolverine will be the
person going back in time we don't know
yet if bishops character will travel
back in time to there were some comic
book versions and some TV versions of
the character that physically traveled
back in time but we don't really know
yet if they'll be physically traveling
into
I'm in this movie but we do know from
recent interviews with bryan singer is
is that James McAvoy is Professor X
character is just super depressed right
now while on the other hand Michael
Fassbender's magneto is just kind of
gaining in power and building his
Brotherhood of mutants so obviously a
big part of the story is them convincing
James McAvoy to join the fight there's
actually this really cool scene in the
teaser clip from comic-con where you see
the scene with both versions of
Professor X talking to each other and
it's basically Patrick Stewart's version
of the character telling James McAvoy
that he has to learn to hope again
honestly I think a big part of changing
this dystopian future is going to be
James McAvoy's character and his call to
action so to speak one of the other
really cool things they did at the comic
con panel was actually kind of intro
Peter Dinklage's character obviously
pretty much everybody already knew who
he was but they just really made it
official and I like some of the viral
images like this do you like this you
like that mustache Bryan Singer actually
kind of laughed his way through the
x-men panel to which I actually I didn't
think was quite a good thing but I mean
I think it's funny obviously but it's
like you know the director was basically
laughing at his spectacular mustache a
little bit and I don't think that peter
dinklage thought it was too funny I
think he's just used to the seriousness
that game of thrones brings one of the
really cool things I feel like we as
fans really want to see though is x-men
going up against x-men so like x-men
generation 1 vs. x-men generation to
honestly that Patrick Stewart and James
McAvoy teaser isn't really so much a
battle as it is just them kind of
psychically talking to each other
through time they haven't really
explained the time-travel mechanism
either but I'll talk about that in the
later video let me know in the comments
which two versions of the x-men
characters would you like to see fight
themselves I mean wouldn't it be awesome
to see Michael Fassbender's magneto go
up against Ian McKellen's magneto who do
you think would win there is actually a
good chance that we could see some stuff
like that from behind the scenes just
some fun stuff obviously not maybe not
officially in the movie on the DVD bonus
features so hold out hope so unlike the
thor trailer we won't be getting a Days
of Future past trailer for a while they
just started filming the movie but I
will be covering Days of Future past as
new information comes out and i will
post the trailer as soon as it comes so
be sure to subscribe to get it in the
meantime be sure to check out my review
that thor trailer by clicking here and
you can learn all about why i think we
need a lot
a movie by clicking here thanks for
watching happy geek week high five
you